aujourd'hui l'europe de démontrer sa
capacité à incarner de réels projets des
projets ambitieux des projets porteurs
d'avenir au moment où emmanuel macron
s'enferme dans une spirale toujours plus
dangereuse celle d'une europe toujours
plus technocratique
avec toujours plus de normes nous les
républicains nous défendons une europe
efficace une europe pragmatique c'est
dans ce cadre que nous vous proposons un
certain nombre de mesures
je pense notamment à la santé à en faire
l'une des causes européenne en
investissant massivement dans la
recherche commune afin de trouver d'ici
cinq ans un remède à la maladie
d'alzheimer
dans le même esprit nous pouvons penser
également à la lutte contre les zones
blanches notamment dans les territoires
ruraux et dans les transports en commun
en investissant massivement dans le
développement de la 4g de la 5g puisque
ce sont un levier c'est un levier
prioritaire pour elle lutter contre la
fracture territoriale
dans le même esprit nous proposons
également barre était l'europe qui ne
marche pas d'arrêter toutes ces formules
qui n'ont aucun sens et de revenir à
l'europe qui fonctionnait c'est à dire à
une europe organisé autour d'un noyau
dur de pays dont la france n'ayant
évidemment qui partagent les mêmes
règles fiscales et sociales
voilà ce que nous proposons nous
proposons également un plan européen des
nouvelles mobilités car les républiques
ou les républicains nous sommes
convaincus que l'afld que l'europe doit
être leader en matière de véhicules
électriques ou encore de transport à
l'hydrogène
ce sont toutes ces propositions que j'ai
envie de défendre sur cette liste les
républicains face à l'europe des normes
nous disons non nous disons oui à
l'europe des projets des projets
novateurs des projets porteurs d'avenir
qui construiront l'union européenne de
demain